Movie sequels are impossible to predict. Some
become classics and some become the most hated
movies of all time. So what makes a sequel
good, and why do sequels have such a hard
time not sucking? Let’s compare similar
sequels to see what works and what doesn’t.
One of the biggest obstacles with a great sequel
is that you have to do something new. Maybe
the first movie worked great, but the sequel
can’t be the same thing or it’ll suck.
The sequels that we all love mix it up and
surprise us.
The first Terminator features Arnold Schwarzenegger
as the villain, and he’s such a terrifying
villain because he’s not even human. He’s
a robotic monster whose only objective is
to kill Sarah Connor. A lazy, unsurprising
sequel would put us in the same world with
the Terminator trying to kill again, but James
Cameron surprises us, and in a spectacular
twist, Arnold is actually sent to protect
John Connor from another, more powerful Terminator.
Now that’s a great sequel.
And then, there’s Speed. The first Speed
is about a cop who tries to rescue civilians
from a bus rigged to explode if any of the
civilians try to get off or the bus slows
down. It’s action packed and suspenseful
from start to finish. The sequel, Speed 2,
has the same general idea, but the bus is
now a luxury cruise ship. The surprise is
amazingly lame. A slow-moving cruise ship
is way less thrilling than the fast moving
bus in the first Speed. The surprise isn’t
a surprise. It’s a let down.
Sequels also need to build. They need to add
something, and what they add has to be good.
22 Jump Street has the same general plot as
21 Jump Street. The only real difference between
the two films is that one takes place in high
school and the other in college. But the second
film adds a whole gag about the movie itself.
They constantly make references to how doing
the same thing over and over again will not
lead to the same results. They’re making
fun of the fact that sequels never work. They
build on 21 Jump Street by now making fun
of themselves. It’s clever, original, unique, and hilarious.
The Hangover: Part II tries to build on the
original. Instead of taking place in Las Vegas,
the sequel is in the much more exotic Thailand.
But that’s really the only addition to the
original. There’s nothing new here. There’s no build.
An inherent problem with feature-length film
is that the amount of possible character development
is limited to the hour and a half length of
the movie. So in a medium like television
we can see so many complex changes in a character
over the course of several seasons whereas
a movie can show maybe one or two major changes.
With a sequel, though, we have a chance to
see characters we love in the original grow
even more. I think any sequel that doesn’t
take advantage of this opportunity for more
character growth is a disappointment. Toy
Story, for example, shows us a whole new character
arc for Woody in the sequel. In the first
film, Woody makes the realization that getting
the most attention isn’t what’s important:
And then, in the sequel, Woody has another
realization that, while his time with Andy
is temporary, he would rather spend his limited time making Andy happy over being displayed in a museum.
Through the sequel, we get further
insight into Woody and his dedication to Andy.
We learn more about Woody’s goals, his fears,
and his obstacles. The sequel added just as
much depth to the main character as the first
film which, in the end, is what turns sequels
into classics. We can see this added depth
to characters in other great sequels like
The Godfather: Part II with Michael Corleone
and The Dark Knight with Bruce Wayne.
When we compare these sequels to something
like Cars 2 and The Hobbit franchise, we see
another way movie sequels can suck. Cars 2
doesn’t show any change to the characters
from the original, and even with almost eight
hours of screen time for The Hobbit series,
we see hardly any character depth in most
of the ensemble cast.
I have to commend the Marvel Cinematic Universe
for knowing how to make great sequels. You
can tell from their consistent continuity,
writing style, crossovers, and brand marketing,
that Disney isn’t making sequels just for
one-time cash grabs. Disney is attempting
to make very long-term profit by creating
a lasting franchise and brand, and it seems
to be working. Their sequels surprise, build,
and add character depth. Think about The Avengers.
We get loads of surprises when our favorite
super heroes fight it out, build on plots
from previous films, and we see tons of character
depth by seeing the conflicts of interest
between each super hero. I’m not saying
Marvel movies are the greatest movies of all
time, but what I am saying is that Marvel
knows how to make sequels, and that’s saying
a lot given the countless disappointments
we’ve seen in sequels.
Making a good sequel to a great original is
definitely a challenge, but I think a big
problem with sequels is that a lot of the
time the studio doesn’t really care if a
sequel is well reviewed. With a successful
original, as long as a sequel is OK, it’s
almost guaranteed to make a profit for the
studio. Remember that despite all the hate
towards sequels like Cars 2, The Hangover:
Part II, and the Star Wars prequels, they
grossed more than their original films. Sequels
create an interesting paradox in the film
industry. To be successful, a film normally
has to show something unique like great special
effects, acting, or plot, but a sequel can
make a profit only by having a recognizable
name and providing nothing unique. So do Hollywood
a favor and stop going to sequels that suck.